what's up ahs fans it looks like fx has
just released a trailer for episode 5
and think story is here to break it all
down you might be wondering how do i do
two videos in a day simple i'm addicted
to the black pill but before we begin if
you haven't hit that like and subscribe
button yet please do i cover all of ahs
so make sure to check out my playlist
and i've also left a link to the preview
in the description below if you want to
check that out before coming back so
let's get into it episode 5 the
penultimate episode of part 1 red tide
is titled gaslight with the caption
reading harry struggles to keep alma
under control doris is pushed past her
limits our first image is doris
stumbling upon her daughter feeding it
cuts a little too early to see exactly
what she's feeding on but considering
doris has already seen alma eating a
dead rabbit this is going to be very
concerning it also along with this shot
here confirms doris is out of the
hospital after suffering a
stress-induced fall in episode 3. a
little further in the trailer we see the
opposite angle of doris reacting to what
alma has done now maybe it's just the
angle but doris doesn't look pregnant
here it's it's got to be the angle right
guys here harry scolds alma for what
appears to be getting caught feeding in
episode 3 he made a deal with her that
only he would provide her meals and it
looks like he's brought something for
her with what appears to be blood around
her mouth doris is back home in bed
telling someone that it's not safe here
it's most likely alma although there's a
minor chance it could be ursula tb karen
tells mickey not to leave her because if
he does they'll kill her karen has
expressed to belle noir before her fear
of the pale ones coming after her and
her protection from them was something
belle noire provided because you
promised to protect me from the others
whatever helps you sleep at night
sweetheart in the season trailer we get
this shot of pale creatures crashing
into what i think is belle noire's house
there's also a figure in the background
who might be the chemist so maybe bel
noir is killed by the pale creatures and
karen is no longer protected karen also
doesn't want mickey to leave perhaps
this is him telling her he'll be off to
la to work in the movies after all
ursula said he's been wanted to write
the next speed racer now this shot of a
hand coming through is really
interesting initially i thought it was
one of the pale ones but there are two
clues which lead me to believe it might
actually be doris one of all the pale
creatures we've seen so far none of them
have worn this type of material two it
looks suspiciously like the material
found on doris's arms later in the
trailer look at these images and let me
know what you think here we get a shot
of doris taking a knife from the wall in
that same shirt material we've seen this
knife holding shot from the season
trailer but they are wearing different
shirts here almas says she doesn't want
to lose this family and doris is scared
that it's already lost and alma suggests
that it won't be lost if she becomes
like quote daddy and i this entire
season alma has talked a lot of smack
about her mother not having any talent
so this might be alma's way of
convincing her mother to take the black
pill knowing it will turn her into one
of the pale ones still no word yet how
lyme disease will play into all this we
get a shot of one of the pale ones
terrorizing the streets and some blood
being twisted from a rag and finally
harry has had enough of alma's playing
and takes her bow if i were to hazard a
guess this is him getting mad at her for
getting caught feeding now this image
has me stumped it's super grainy at
night of a pale creature eating a rabbit
it's most likely this person which some
have argued is doris having undergone a
full transformation from taking the
black pill but i want to hear what you
guys think the one thing i didn't really
see here is a wedding ring on the left
hand to fully see if it was doris but
hey it might have come off or it's just
so grainy we can't really see it this
shot of a black pill mixed with a bunch
of others leads me to believe this is
doris you can barely make out her
wedding ring there and she'd be taking a
bunch of prenatal vitamins anyway in the
background here you can also make out an
iv in the corner perhaps she's on one
when she comes home from the hospital
and here's harry looking a little worse
for wear and this shot of someone
cleaning up blood in a bathroom the
sepia almost black and white tone here
suggests this might be a flashback not
exactly sure who this person is even
after cross-referencing the ring with
previous footage here's a shot of doris
clutching something in her hand almost
as if she's holding a baby maybe it's
these rags besides alma that we see here
some scissors these are kinda random but
they might be important later and karen
walking into the ocean i think this
matches with the season trailer where we
see her walking away from a dead body
toward the beach with blood on her face
and some have suggested that this is
mickey here we have doris in front of a
bunch of interior design stuff take note
of the vomit in front of her suggesting
she may have tried to take the pill and
puked it up we've also seen her vomit
earlier on in the season also this might
just be the angle but it almost looks as
though she's being sucked into the bed
maybe her legs are behind her and
finally we have this shot of a pale
person on the streets of town with
another one behind him or her it looks
like some sort of attack is imminent
with only two more episodes until part 1
wraps it looks like things are ramping
up extremely fast i want to hear what
you think will happen in the upcoming
weeks in the comments below and i hope
you'll consider liking and subscribing i
come out with new videos every week
thanks for watching be sure to check out
my episode breakdowns and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember daddy loves you very much